here's the thing the culture that is
created by the radicals in the schools
well it bleeds up to every aspect of our
culture this is kind of an amazing story
and it is indicative of just where we
stand as a culture right now according
to the hollywood reporter harry potter
and the sorcerer's stone stars and
filmmaker chris columbus are reuniting
for a previously announced 20th
anniversary retrospective on hbo max
there's one notable omission from the
list of participants the person who
created all of harry potter jk rowling
why of course well we know the answer
why j.k rowling says that men exist in
women exist she has as they say a turf a
trans-exclusionary radical feminist when
it became a radical feminist ideal to
point out that women exist is beyond me
it's insane so
according to the left you are now a
radical feminist crazy if you oppose
pornography and believe women exist
so
welcome to the traditional conservative
side of the aisle jk rowling
harry potter's 20th anniversary return
to hogwarts will stream january 1st on
hbo max with a linear debut on tbs and
cartoon network in the spring
the failure to to name it rallying is
interesting rallying sparked backlash
according to the hollywood reporter from
the trans community after saying that
transgender individuals should be
defined by their biological sex well
actually no what she said is that their
biological sex is the only way that you
can label people by sex proclaiming that
a male as a female is idiotic which is
true sources close to the project note
the retrospective will focus on the
creation of the film and the central
cast and team rowling will be featured
in archival footage she just won't make
a new appearance so we'll use the old
footage of jk rowling but we have to
pretend that she died years ago before
she started with this whole women exist
thing
it's incredible we're now erasing some
of the most prominent people in our
culture over the fact that they believe
that women exist
that is where we are right now and this
is part of a broader sensorius push by
the left to just get rid of anyone who
disagrees with them
it's the reason why you see the left
pushing on facebook and pushing on
youtube and pushing on twitter to bar
people who disagree with them
shutting off the access to the public is
the only way of allowing radicals to win
because if these battles are fought in
the public sphere the left loses the
radical left will lose most americans
most people on earth do not believe that
men can become women most people in the
west do not believe you should be
primarily identified as an oppressor or
a member of depressed class based on
immutable characteristic
most people don't believe that and so
that leaves the radical left with one
choice try to shut down everybody who
disagrees and they're becoming more and
more overt about this it's not like
they're hiding the ball anymore right
whether it is trying to get professors
fired for mouthing platitudes like merit
ought to matter more than race or
whether you're talking about nicole
wallace on msnbc suggesting that fox
news is like a terror group i i gotta
tell you it is incredible to watch the
left just unmask in real time
i think they've done more damage to the
party than anything i'm sure you do but
if we want to go through that i think
there are liars and conspiracy theorists
on msnbc and on cnn also so maybe i'll
write a book about all that but that's
not what this book is about
in that section of the book i'm talking
to republicans about the way i believe
we need to deal with media to be most
effective for winning
the conspiracy theorists and truth
deniers which nobody else
on either side of the aisle is writing
about right now other than me no one
else is writing about that do you want
to solve them that's my question
all the proliferation of conspiracy
theories without dealing with fox news
it's like solving terrorism without
dealing with the terrorists well look
that's your opinion i disagree with your
opinion
okay so fox news is the promulgator of
conspiracy theories says the anchor on
msnbc which msnbc which spent four long
years claiming that the steele dossier
was probably real
absolutely incredible stuff of course
the goal of saying that fox news is like
a terrorist group is to get fox news
thrown off the air they've been very
clear about all of this
this is the goal
if they can't win then they will attempt
to silence that is what they're going to
do at the school board level it's why
they are attempting to rip your kids
away from you
it is why they are intent on
indoctrinating your children without you
being able to see over their shoulder
the goal is to control the entire
narrative in every aspect of american
life and they will do that either by top
down stranglehold on institutions or
they will do it by essentially telling
you that it's no business of yours how
they raise your children well the
backlash is coming and it's coming
strong and it should come because this
is the fight of our time and it's the
fight for the next generation
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang